à quelques reprises depuis le début de
la crise
alexandra stréliski a invité les
internautes chez elle pour un concert de
salon moi je me suis dit qu'est ce que
je peux faire
qu'est-ce que je peux faire dans ma vie
à moi j'ai rien à part jouer du piano
joué du piano puis pis il a fait du bien
aux gens tant mieux si ça fait du bien
aux gens je le vois je reçois des gens
sont tellement de messages tellement
commandes s'est-il de concerts en ligne
se multiplient partout sur la planète
dans tous les styles musicaux les
internautes sont au rendez vous voilà de
quoi finement sa peine au quotidien qui
n'est pas toujours facile on peut voir
le nombre de personnes qui participent
on peut voir les gens commenté donc on a
encore ses sentiments la proximité c'est
important pour les gens plus jamais
aujourd'hui pendant le confinement
parce qu'on est pris dans la maison
qu'il faut se trouver des idées qu'il
faut s'occuper
le centre national des arts dispose d'un
budget de 700 mille dollars pour
rémunérer les artistes qui font des
performances en ligne
en deux semaines ils ont reçu plus de
quatre mille candidatures et les
performances qu'ils ont diffusé ont été
vues près de deux millions de fois
l'occasion de faire de belles
découvertes
[Musique]
des artistes trouvent de nouveaux
publics et des publics trop de nouveaux
artistes qui ne connaissait pas
contrairement aux concerts traditionnels
les prestations en ligne facilite le
dialogue entre les artistes et le public
et permettent une nouvelle forme
d'intimité on peut sentir même l'émotion
des musiciens qui sont soit qu'ils ont
mis qui sont très seuls qui s'inquiète
qui ont peut-être pas pour leur avenir
je trouve que tout ça est palpable et
tout ça entre dans la performance
musicale une nouvelle façon de faire les
choses qui risque d'avoir un impact même
lorsque les salles rouvriront mais c'est
sûr que ça va être différent
il faut rester ouvert à ça il faut
s'adapter on est capable on est on est
début d'été plus résiliente qu'on pense
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal